رسائل سريه من واشنطن الى كيف عنوانها
الحرب في اوكرانيا
ومضمونها بوتين والمفاوضات
ورغم ان واشنطن ترى ان موسكو ليست راغبه
باجراء محادثات سلام الا انها وبحسب
واشنطن بوست تشجع اوكرانيا سرا على التخلي
عن رفضهم العلني المشاركه في اي محادثات
السلامه
لكن بين سطور الرسائل الهدف ليس الضغط على
اوكرانيا للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات انما
محاوله محسوبه لضمان ان تحافظ كيف على دعم
دول اخرى تقرير الصحيفه كشف ايضا ان رفض
الرئيس الاوكراني
اجراء محادثات مع نظيره الروسي تسبب بقلق
في اجزاء من اوروبا وافريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه وهي الدول التي تعاني التداعيات
الاقتصاديه للحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من بيلاروسيا الى اسطنبول مفاوضات
الجانبين ظلت عالقه عند مطلب كل طرف لكن
ضم روسيا الاخير لاربعه اقاليم اوكرانيه
فجر قرارا واقعه زنسكي يقضي بعدم التفاوض
مع روسيا الا في حال سحبت كافه قواتها
رفض كل منزل لنسكي وبوتن للحوار وتراجع
حماس بعض الدول الاوروبيه جعل المفاوضات
اكثر تعقيدا وصعوبه من اي وقت مضى خاصه مع
دخول الصراع الروسي الاخراني شهره الثامن
[موسيقى]
لكن على ما يبدو فان التقدم الاخراني
ميدانيا ربما شجع الاداره الامريكيه الى
دفعها للمفاوضات في ظل الازمات الاقتصاديه
التي يشهدها العالم